oh I didn't see you there  you and I both know that we're going to  be here for a while  guys we need to be foraging with root  vegetables  hey stop we need the oil for our skin  hair and teeth exhale the sands from  your soul and I need to remind everybody  that I am unable to do any heavy lifting  as I pulled my growing doing yoga check  it out coconut headphones water filter  ocean water goes in the top fresh water  the bottom I'm sure everyone's doing  right now building stupid huts points  don't have identified the berries these  on the other hand are extremely  dangerous we have to avoid these I wish  I had a slim hat and a popsicle thread  we're gonna die here